- Je me rappelle que le taxi
nous déposait là et on
traversait par ici,
mais ce n'était pas aussi
aménagé comme ça, avant.
- Lovejoyce Amavi est émotif :
c'est la première fois
qu'il revient au chemin Roxham.
Originaire du Togo, il a
traversé la frontière pour
demander l'asile en août 2017.
LOVEJOYCE AMAVI
- On arrive, on descend avec
ges, on nous arrêtait,
on ne savait pas combien
de temps ça allait prendre,
lait être acceptés
ou non.
- Il sera retenu 10 jours
aux douanes avant d'arriver
dans la région de Montréal.
Ce parcours, il le raconte
dans un livre qu'il vient
de publier.
- Quand on est immigrant
ou demandeur d'asile,on va voust
de faire de l'entretien ménager,
de travailler comme agent
de sécurité ou d'aller
dans des choses très rapides
pour gagner de l'argent.
Mine de rien, on a quand même
des expériences de travail,
des expériences de vie,
des compétences qu'on peut
mettre à contribution.
- Marjorie Villefranche
abonde dans le même sens.
Son organisme a aidé de nombreux
demandeurs d'asile arrivés
par le chemin Roxham.
MARJORIE VILLEFRANCHE,
dir. générale, Maison d'Haïti
- Ils ont dû sacrifier ce qu'ils
savaient déjà, c'est-à-dire leur
métier, leur expérience, etc.
- Depuis 2017, des vagues
de migrants sont entrées au pays
par le chemin Roxham.
Et cette année, ce nombre
a atteint des records.
Conséquences?
- Je trouve que l'idée qu'on
avait d'une personne qui demande
l'asile, c'est une personne
qui demande à être protégée.
Et comment se fait-il que
maintenant, quand on parle
de demandeur d'asile, on voit
quelqu'un qui vient nous
envahir? Ce qui manque,
je dirais, c'est l'acceptation,
c'est la non-exclusion,sion,sio,
c'est le fait de sentir
qu'on est un citoyen
à part entière.
- Lovejoyce Amavi saluesaluesale
l'accueil qu'il a reçu
en arrivant au pays,
mais il voudrait lui aussi
que certaines perceptions
changent
- Au bout des chiffres
économiques ou des défis
d'emploi, il y a des vies
humaines. Ces vies humaines,
s parcours,
c'est des histoires,
c'est des cultures,
c'est des connaissances.
- Un peu plus de crès
avoir franchi le chemin Roxham,
Lovejoyce estime avoir trouvé
sa patrie ici.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon, Radn